additional one i was like when
when my gosh i was like do you know that
you're a thousand years old you [ __ ]
dinosaur like your your humble times are
different now yeah she goes oh why do
you guys i would know better i was like
no you don't you haven't been to korea
in 30 [ __ ] years
we did this per the advice of all of her
relatives and the people that i know
they go oh we don't do that stuff
anymore it's more like modern more
simplified and if you're looking for
those old-fashioned humble stuff they're
kind of hard to find because not a lot
of people in five four three
two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast i am your host david so and we
have ed park vp back in the house what's
up
cheers fancy soju ohio ohio
uh my brother-in-law steven got this for
me i think for my birthday or you know
to be honest i don't remember who gave
it to me if i'm gonna give credit to him
because he's been he's been a great
brother-in-law to me so far
gives you the credit so you know what
funny thing is like
you know i always talk to kids about
you know like this idea of forgiving
your you know parents and you know kind
of understanding where they come from
and you know learning how to be very
empathetic yeah and i got to tell you
sometimes it's really [ __ ] hard dude
because sometimes they're just [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
bro let me tell you something so
i told this on the other podcast with
tim i'll tell it here again
so
we went to korea with the explicit idea
or plan to visit family you know before
me and marielle have kids yeah and um
take engagement photos right and so if
you guys know korean friends you'll see
if you go to their parents house they
have these
you know typically like two wedding
photos you have one with the suit and
you have the other one in the
traditional humble right
well that has evolved over time
it's not there's a modern humble now
okay it's a lot more simplified way more
clean the designs aren't the multiple
red blue yellow green and everything
else um they're a lot more simplified
and very clean and cute looking so we
decided to go there and it was a whole
ordeal so when you do this hanbok thing
um there's this specific place in korea
that's next to one of the bigger palaces
that everybody gets their engagement
photos out there the one that used to be
a zoo right yeah
[Laughter]
so that's a whole other thing yeah
so we go there
we get the photos done it's a seven hour
ordeal i get my makeup done for crying
out loud yeah and so apparently the
place that we went to go get our
quote-unquote makeup and hair done is a
really really famous place which we
didn't know we found out through her
relatives yeah they're like oh you went
there and they said did you see any
celebrities and apparently there were
celebrities in there getting their
makeup done wow but i don't know who the
[ __ ] they are right but they were
telling me like oh that's a really
famous uh comedian that person is a very
famous comedian yeah oh [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] know yeah uh it's a seven hour
deal very [ __ ] long and we honestly
did this for our parents because they
wanted engagement photos mary and i
don't really care for that stuff
so
marielle kind of told me he goes oh we
should just print out the photos and
then give it to our parents right i was
like no i'll send them a couple of
samples that they send over so they can
get really excited for it so i send the
photos over and for some [ __ ] reason
i thought that my mom was a normal human
being
and i said it to her and the first thing
she says is that's all you got
bro i was [ __ ] pissed that's it yeah
that's exactly how she responds she goes
that's it how come you can get more
photos and i'm like these are just
samples yeah and we're just showing you
and she goes oh well you know i have
other friends who did you know multiple
books and you only did one and i'm like
i will [ __ ] sock you in your chest
you stupid stupid [ __ ] why didn't you
spend more money yeah
it's like didn't you tell me my whole
life
yeah and she goes and then the thing
that really pissed me off i was like
listen
she goes well i know other people who
did like the traditional one i was like
when
when oh my gosh i was like do you know
that you're a thousand years old you
[ __ ] dinosaur like your your humble
times are different now yeah
guys
you haven't been to korea in 30 [ __ ]
years
we did this per the advice of all of her
relatives and the people that i know
they go oh we don't do that stuff
anymore it's more like modern more
simplified and if you're looking for
those old-fashioned humble stuff they're
kind of hard to find because not a lot
of people get that
my mom's telling me how it works over
there even though i went to korea and i
talked to the business people and i did
it you know based on their part of their
recommendation but she saw it in a cape
drama
but she saw it on let me tell you what
you just said that just [ __ ] and she
just started adding on she goes oh i see
oh he's like okay i get it you didn't
want to you don't you want to do the
other one because you couldn't pay for
it i was like
dude
i have never wanted to sock my mom so
fast i i told you being a clown was not
a good idea i was going to [ __ ] this
lady up i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and then she goes you know what
you're stressing me out i'm like i'm
stressing you out
yeah
this is like they put on it's your fault
how do they always flip it around she
goes you're stressing me out right now
i'm just gonna hang up i was like wait
why are you she hangs up on me
and he's like this is an international
cause
[Laughter]
bro
i was [ __ ] pissed here's the here's
the [ __ ] topper on the ship send it
to my dad right
i get a i get a text message from my dad
and it says
check your check your mail i left the
package for you i'm like what is this
package right i check the next day i get
the package i open it up
it's printed photos of the sample photos
i gave him that he
did edited like smooth your face he put
a a [ __ ] uh uh gaussian blur halo oh
nice nice
he put like the armenians do yes
it had like those little little [ __ ]
wire frame flowers over it
and so he edited the [ __ ] photos i
gave him i'm like oh my god the most
insulting [ __ ] i've ever received in my
life i tore that [ __ ] up and threw it in
the garbage can they had like water
marks on it
don't duplicate
you know and he just [ __ ] just did
all that [ __ ] to my stuff and then he's
like super proud of it
trademarks her face
i actually duplicate he's suing me right
now
[Laughter]
he [ __ ] edits the photo photo because
he didn't like him is he learning
photoshop this full piss and then i was
so mad my brother had to call him and
like what's wrong with you he goes he
goes why would you do that and and my
brother was telling me that he explained
to me because why would you do that he
goes what's so wrong about that i was
like let me ask you something i was like
if if somebody get you gave somebody a
gift and they dismantled it and said if
this one's better would you feel okay he
goes no he goes but that's that's
different
i'm like
my parents are so i always and i told my
mom this i was like listen if you treat
me this way your kid's worse than you do
strangers there's something wrong right
maybe it's like a parent buying a kid a
a honda civic and then he starts putting
all this jdm [ __ ] on it
now you know how it feels
you put a cd player
inside of the susan trooper
they [ __ ] pissed me off i was so
[ __ ] upset and all i kept thinking
was like i'm trying to be empathetic but
i'm like is it because they're old i was
like nope
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] no they're
better than you
i know my mom was like oh so you just
because you went to korea
and you and you got it from that
business you think you know better about
it i'm like exactly yeah
that is exactly what i did
i was literally in their face and we
talked about that
and we had a whole this our discussion
about our choices yeah yeah yeah so yes
i do know better than you you negotiated
the costs yeah like what the [ __ ] is she
talking about she goes oh i know these
other people i was like how old are they
he was like you know your uncles i'm
like
they got married in the 80s i was like
dude when they [ __ ] had humble son
that was just close to them
just keep talking about [ __ ] like you
no more it was just their [ __ ] work
clothes oh my god stupid apple
so you just got back from korea in the
meantime like a lot of [ __ ] was
happening all the shootings all this
other crazy [ __ ] dave chappelle oh my
god yeah that happened you know who was
there danielle oh my gosh she was at
that show she was on the show and she
texted me that's how i found out oh wow
i just saw dave chappelle get tackled
i'm like where at the hollywood bowl and
it was by this person that looked like
it could have been his kid
this half asian half black dude well
i heard like it's just because he got
[ __ ] up in the face so bad he looked
asian oh okay
but his name is isaiah lee but black
people do have the last name lee too
like robert e lee right
i mean i mean that's the southern yeah
general but um
but yeah in that meantime like you're
we're seeing all these [ __ ] shootings
and they're happening over and over
again and it's like what what was the
reaction out there when you're walking
around seeing koreans and they hear the
news is it even in in their news or
lexicon
they got their own [ __ ] to worry about
right well the thing about like
you know i talked about the song with uh
with edric uh was like the idea of one
of the biggest things that i noticed was
how community-based korea was versus
america and you know i feel really weird
saying this but i'm like why did my
parents move
it's kind of nice to hear you know i i'm
guessing because it wasn't nice in the
80s at the time yeah and so that's the
one i guess like if i could say
something that makes me really proud to
be korean is how resilient our our
nation and culture is right yeah the
fact that from war and devastation how
we how technologically advanced places
yeah record time in human history to go
from a [ __ ] stone age after the war
to like boom like economy like eighth in
the world yeah and the idea of like
american elitism right is very weird to
me when i go to south korea and then i
come back and i feel like i just came
into a third world country
like they got health care you know they
got public transportation clean and nice
out there and everything is
technologically advanced there's free
wi-fi [ __ ] everywhere yeah 5g
everywhere too right it's just it
everything makes sense public
transportation is faster than driving
your car and it's accessible everywhere
it costs less than a it costs about a
dollar uh u.s to get on a bus and go to
a destination yeah what the [ __ ] would i
have a car
you know i mean yeah why why would i
ever have a car makes absolutely no
sense and i come back here and it just
looks like ass people don't care about
their jobs there's no like pride in the
stuff that they do and
one of the things i noticed too is that
a lot of people who are in tourist areas
a lot of these korean people they want
foreigners who come here to realize how
great korea is before they leave yes yes
that is their pride their pride yeah for
sure they they that's how much they are
proud of being korean they go oh you
didn't have a good meal well guess what
go to this restaurant you'll have a
really great meal because they want
people to leave here knowing how great
their country just like [ __ ] yeah it's
like i went to this state and i didn't
like it
yeah that was like let's try here try
here yeah nope like i was telling edric
too there was um the lady that we went
to to get our pcr test before we left
she was asking us if we had good food
here because if we didn't she was going
to buy us a meal before we leave back to
the states
because she wanted us to realize how she
goes i don't want you to leave here
thinking that korea is not great so yeah
if you didn't get a good meal i'm going
to tell one of the nurses to go buy you
a lunch before you leave that's [ __ ]
awesome you know
i have never experienced something like
that here yeah that kind of hospitality
isn't even in korean-americans i know
but that's i feel like the korean
americans are all bandits
that came over yeah yeah have you you
know met like koreans from new york and
yeah yeah yeah they have a different
mindset right i think they're the types
that had the goals like specifically to
go to ivy league schools and go to
really great colleges yeah but the west
coast korean americans are like
vagabonds
out of korea
like the korean people like that i met
here their parents was like well your
dad is i used to be a gunpowder [ __ ] i'm
like the [ __ ]
but my dad i mean my dad was a pastor so
he you know he was good but at the end
of the day like when i came here i'm
like damn like korea kind of has this
whole system i mean they're educated i'm
pretty sure they have a lot of flaws i'm
looking at it through the lens of
somebody who was uh visiting yeah but
it's it's kind of nice being in a
country where there's like
a sense of community
you know what i mean like people care
about each other yeah and uh
i think for a lot of korean people who
live there they might say like well it's
not like that everywhere 100 true i'm
only seeing it once again through what i
saw within two weeks but there is a
juxtaposition between like american
individuality versus like this korean
community
very very [ __ ] different it's how
they approach their jobs the pro how
they work it's it's vastly different
from america you know i'm kind of like i
came in here i was like man dude this
guy moved korea bro
nobody cares about me here dude i mean i
feel that all the time you know like but
that's what we're kind of seeing i mean
like while you were gone like news with
like roe v wade that kind of [ __ ] that
leak oh man we even talked about no way
and then there's all you know the
shootings um and every time these
[ __ ]
crazy events
that are happening like what we're
seeing is literally just two sides yeah
yeah yeah and screaming and yelling at
each other and this latest shooting in
texas um
19 people dead total i believe two staff
members i think yeah so it's like 21
total or something like that and most of
them like second or fourth graders
um my cousin was my cousin lives in
texas he was crying his kid didn't die
but just the idea of it yeah you know um
yeah it's three there was the oc one and
then there was also the uh buffalo the
buffalo one which was yeah
that one was crazy too
i mean that was
like
i believe racially motivated
yeah you know they like buffalo i
literally thought it was a white town i
didn't know they had a small black
community and he targeted that black
community which is already small yeah
buffalo is cold as [ __ ] too uh yeah it's
like right next to the [ __ ] niagara
falls
right and it was so funny because when i
went there was doing wintertime and they
they took me to see niagara falls and
they're like look i'm like i'm get me
the [ __ ] out of here
it's so cold
i just came from los angeles man and
then because of the falls it's just like
30 miles per hour winds blasting you in
the face i can't see anything like get
me home but um the oc one's [ __ ]
crazy too because it's asian on asian
crime it's asian hate
like
well how do we
talk through this one okay it was a
chinese nationalist who went to go kill
taiwanese christians
genius farts this podcast is sponsored
by better help life can be overwhelming
and many people are burned out without
even knowing it my friends i could go on
and read this ad from this piece of
paper but i don't need it because i love
better
help it is one of the best things that
have entered my life because i love the
mental clarity i get from speaking to my
therapist especially how convenient it
is i can do video chat sessions i could
call one ever message them and they'll
get right back to me i really really
needed it especially during pandemic
when all that craziness was going on and
it's still going on now so now better
help is right in my back pocket with my
fat ass so better up his customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched up with a
therapist in under 48 hours genius brain
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com genius that's
betterhelp.com
genius because the idea of it is that
people who are chinese nationalists they
don't want taiwanese people to have
their own nation like you're not
taiwanese you are chinese right so
basically he went to go kill his own
countrymen yeah
it doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense so you're a part of me now die
yeah
what the [ __ ] how does that make sense
this shooting itself is in the bottom
rung because people can't understand
this asian on age and
crime let's say yeah um but then yeah
when you look into it just yeah
obviously it doesn't make sense like
when you look at it like it's not a
racial motive it's this nationalist
motive but it's like you're in america
yeah bro what are you doing america
you're they're here for their freedom
because you don't want it there you
don't want it here either
no i'm gonna be a [ __ ] redneck and be
like get the [ __ ] out of this country
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
you know i get to get the [ __ ] out hey
let me tell you something you need to go
back to where you come from yeah i'm
this close to the c word you know
like get the [ __ ] out of here man
they're here specifically because you
don't like it over there yeah why i
that's what i'm saying it just doesn't
make sense and obviously we could chalk
it up to being this this guy being crazy
yeah but even
just
the the logical fallacy behind it is so
huge it's glaring yeah it just
it doesn't add up and i think this is
like one of those things for other
people who are outside to kind of
realize about like asian people in
general is that we're very much not so
like any other type of like culture or
nation there's no it's not a monolithic
type of thing there's no
the asian identity is so vast there's no
korean person that hyper relates to like
a vietnamese story either or like
cambodian you know chinese hmong
mongolian everything is so [ __ ]
different right yeah but i feel like
when you come into the states people
kind of see this this blanket asian
person i mean because they they do it
too um latin americans they're all
mexican
you know they do it to uh africans it's
literally the thing is that africa is a
country itself yeah yeah yeah but for
some reason there are spaniards there
are french there are german people there
are swedes there are norwegians it's
like okay wait you can differentiate
white people but you won't give us the
space yeah you know either well the
thing that blows people's mind even
something so stupid is this they meet
somebody from spain and they go well
you're white
like what you [ __ ] you're talking
about [ __ ] you're [ __ ] talking about
bro it's in europe you jackass yeah you
know i was like no but you speak spanish
yeah it's like
how do you explain that to somebody but
that's that's what i'm saying like i'm
not very global either but that was just
a small example where literally you'll
hear that [ __ ] all the time you'll see
people who like travel to spain and the
first thing they do when they come back
dude there's a lot of white people
they were expecting like some east l.a
mexicans in spain
you know hey what's up oh welcome to
[ __ ] spain
you know like the dark people in spain
is because they have roots in north
africa
that shit's [ __ ] crazy to me yeah but
you know but that's like once again like
people just don't understand that too
and then you know we also talked about
and touched on this too where i was
trying to explain why
you know people like how come all asian
people just don't support all asian
people i'm like that would be nice
and i understand but it's just like oh
you gooks look alike
you know so you you should understand
what you guys are going through yeah no
like i i agree yeah but at the same time
it's a little more complicated than that
it's not like if i spoke korean to
somebody who speaks um i don't know
cantonese they're gonna be like i
understand most of it
they're not gonna understand at all it's
a completely different language and
culture you know yeah but they literally
think we're all one people but i mean
looking at the situation in the oc is
clearly seeing like
um it's almost like what happened with
uh the irish in the 90s right
like protestant versus catholics they
were bombing each other like car bombs
that doesn't make any sense either yeah
it doesn't make sense to us either like
what can't you just
what because one side is so pissed that
the other prays to mary
you know the virgin mary you know and
they hate it so much that they blow each
other up in car bombs right and then for
us it's to become then
apathetic yeah that it doesn't involve
us right that
it
the best thing to do is do nothing about
it right and that's a big thing that i
i'm thinking about with why we have such
problems you know with the complication
of these things
and it's because
the most simplest answer
is because we can't be kind to one
another
and we can't
like literally talk about some things
because we can't respect each other
and that is basically the main theme of
everywhere
like wait everything everywhere all at
once
that movie by the way because we'll
definitely do that review to this it's
like yeah that
movie is the most complicated [ __ ]
like i only got to see it once and it
was already hard to see it because i was
telling ed
first time i tried to go watch it the
[ __ ] speakers blew out so i thought i
was like whoever composed this [ __ ]
sex
you were in movie review mode like what
the [ __ ] is this mix yeah i was like why
is the [ __ ] volume on all the
dialogue super
loud i was over here making notes i was
like dude ed i don't know what you're
talking about
i was like so hyped about you know this
movie's awesome and then uh our buddy
ray he does sound for a living yeah you
can see him look a little visibly upset
and he gets outside he goes the speakers
are blown out i'm like
this makes sense because i was like
because there were parts too where you
would see somebody's mouth move and then
there was no sound coming out i'm like
oh is this like an easter egg yeah so i
was like completely misinterpreting the
movie throughout the whole beginning you
just lost an entire channel of audio
basically yeah like i see and so like
like for example in the martial arts
parts or it was literally in the first
30 minutes of the film
where she started going into the
multiverse yeah and the bodyguard
it was where uh wayman was fighting
he's raymond or wayman in the movie
wayman wayman he's wayman right yes the
chinese version of it the hong kong
version so wayman starts [ __ ] up the
bodyguard which is our buddy brian bryan
lee
right right and but all the sound
effects were super muted that
i'm like dude man this [ __ ] sucks
yeah like you more or less felt bad
about it because like it could have been
great yeah but the sound mix
i was like dude i'm gonna [ __ ] find
this guy and beat his ass
but then you find out the speakers were
blown i tried to go watch it again all
the tickets were sold out and then so i
finally got to see it and i didn't
realize when watching the film and the
reason why it's so hard for me to digest
is because
there's so many little things that have
really great nuance to it that i want to
think about but it always jumps into
another universe yeah and then i'm like
oh yeah i didn't i'll come back to that
and i watched it i'm like oh [ __ ] well
i'll come back to that and next thing
you know i'm like what did i watch yeah
the pacing of this movie is so [ __ ]
fast right off the bat
right it's like this is the speed you
know ketchup getting into gear um
which
i i appreciate because i love movies
that have a re-watch factor yeah that
you're supposed to watch it again and
again and it gets better it gets better
and better one of the things that i
really liked i mean just off the jump
and this is one of the things that i'm
very critical about a lot of people who
are
trying to write right and i see this a
lot in a lot of like asian american
filmmakers yeah um
it's where they kind of um
they're trying to hit an emotional note
with somebody right that's something
that's like a personal struggle that you
see like within the asian american
community right but they hit it too hard
like the nail on the head like little
too hard they verbally say these issues
out rather than just being there and
present through the experience that
you've had and what i mean by that and
this movie does a great example of that
is where
um michelle yo has a daughter
her daughter is a lesbian yeah
her daughter and michelle yo doesn't
have to say through dialogue you're
uncomfortable with me being gay
it doesn't have to be said yeah and in
fact in most family dynamics it's not
said like that it's done through certain
behaviors the way that they say things
yeah and the way michelle yo would
address her girlfriend was her friend is
here yeah which you see a lot in asian
american families where instead of
confronting things head on they'll do
like these subtle things to show how
uncomfortable they are and that's what
that's just one little thing that i
liked about the film yeah it's like oh
this is a social issue that we have
within like an asian american family
especially dealing with homosexuality
yeah but it wasn't this person with a
spotlight with their hand on the wall
going
you don't know what it's like to be gay
and asian
it's like
okay who talks like that yeah and how
does that show a real family dynamic too
many young filmmakers do that you don't
need to do
show don't tell shout out i was waiting
for you to finish so i just say the
exact same thing
show don't tell and this movie shows
in fact like i think the average length
of one shot and a cut is like half a
second just so fast and i just want to
say up front like i literally predict um
an
editing oscar nomination for this movie
you know i also see people trying to
imitate yeah what this film did yeah you
know there's always like
there's always a time when like two
movies come out at the same time and
they're like have the same theme you
know like deep impact and armageddon
yeah yeah yeah yeah no olympus has
fallen and white house down or some [ __ ]
and then this and doctor strange too
came out
and i think this is the far superior
film
yeah and i also too
i didn't get to see doctor strange but i
already know that's the case because
when you have these big budget films
like marvel films there's a lot more
that goes along with it than just the
director and the writer coming together
um production or whatever and trying to
see how this is going to flesh out yeah
there's certain things that major
studios want and need in order for this
field to be highly successful yeah right
and i think like one of the films that
debated that we talked about that was a
guardians of the galaxy because nobody
had any expectations before guardians of
the galaxy yeah so james gunn really got
to do whatever the [ __ ] he wanted right
and he's kind of set a tone for like oh
we like this tone and now the other i
feel like this other studios are in the
ears of other directors who are doing
marvel films and be like hey we want it
like this yeah let's put more jokes in
it
you know it needs to be a little more
funnier you know which is really hard to
imitate you can imitate but you can't
duplicate that [ __ ] right yeah because
james gunn it's james gunn yeah yeah
yeah and like in in the case of this
movie everything everywhere all at once
the daniels
um i first heard of them because they
did the turn down for what uh music
video
yeah oh
and then they did wait are they korean
no that's what i thought too every time
we know a quan we think they're korean
right chinese
chinese
it could have been good
forever but every now and then i meet a
quan and then korean and then every now
and then yeah we totally mistake a quan
and they're chinese god damn it okay we
lose out on that credit
well you guys have taiwan and now you
got them all right no but i commend him
like he has
he's they've got this adhd kind of
mindset and they perfectly translated
onto the screen
this film is like edgar wright meets
kung fu hustle
you know and i really think that like
these guys are next up in line to direct
a marvel film if they're going to go
into the multiverse these guys
understand it like um and these
[ __ ] must be on crack dude
because i
they're on adderall for
something that they got adhd it's very
rare
i wouldn't say rare because like i also
had a very similar feeling watching the
batman watching this where the opening
shot looks so good i was like this is
going to be a good film
right because even the way that they
compose the shots
looked really really [ __ ] good dude
yeah they had to do so much of it
practically
um because you know they're music video
directors right and and so they've got
a great eye for the visual art
right and um they also did their own
special effects you know only five
people
did the visual effects on this they they
did the cgi
including the daniels themselves really
yeah
so like
this is like literally like [ __ ]
nitty gritty film making
and they visually got everything they
needed to as things as like
complicated things were happening
you know what was so hilarious too was
when i was looking at the character who
was playing wayman right first of all if
you guys watched indiana indiana jones
right he was gunny's yeah he was the the
asian kid yeah dr jones dr jones yeah
and nobody
has seen him in a very long time and
that i was reading an article where he
was saying there just wasn't roles for
any asian people yeah in the 90s and
2000s yeah so he took a fat hiatus and a
break because he was like there's
nothing out here for me but now that
there's like this huge wave of of like
inclusivity happening and this is where
he gets this role funny thing was when i
was watching and i was like dude that
guy looks just like jackie jackie chan i
was like what the [ __ ]
he has a high pitched voice by jackie
chan and i found out originally that
role was for jackie chan yeah
yeah
he looks just like jackie chan dude yeah
it was supposed to be like uh jackie
chan and michelle yo's role mm-hmm right
and he and he was supposed to make the
main lead but according to like how we
see it play out in the third act
i think it would be too hard for jackie
chan to play this role because of how he
disowned his son yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah for smoking and selling
marijuana right yeah and so it would be
hard and kind of hypocritical for him to
play this role to reconcile in you know
in the third act
while he has his own you know family
issues i guess yeah it's interesting
though because i when i saw it too i'm
like oh jackie chan could totally
[ __ ] play this [ __ ] but
you know
it's not like the replacement was any
worse he's he's so [ __ ] good dude
this podcast is brought to you by secret
society a contemporary fashion basics
line that's for everybody i know that
you guys out there who are in to
high-end streetwear and contemporary
basics that you have to pay an arm and a
leg for great quality well guess what we
do the same thing and i dare i say it
even better the vintage hughes
collection that's out right now is
amazing i'm talking about the softest
french terry you've ever had 30 ounces
for the shorts 30 ounces for the hoodie
that's the quality we put into our work
check out our oversized tees we have the
the vintage puff print on the shirts the
hoodies the sweaters [ __ ] uh may sing
we outdid ourselves with this one if
you're sick and tired of getting good
quality stuff for a gajillion dollars
check out secret society you will not be
disappointed you will walk outside
wearing our stuff and people will stop
you and ask you where you got them and
you say from secret society what you
know about that ain't no secret because
i'm wearing it up right now and now you
wanna you know [ __ ] me
check out secret society vintage huge
collection is out now cop it look good
and remember my friends
basics never die
yeah there's a there's a there's a huge
difference and i really do think this
with a lot of like
um older generation asian actors i feel
like their skill is just so [ __ ] good
i think that we do have a long way to go
where there's a lot of people now who
want to be asian americans who want to
be really great actors and actresses
because they like
the idea of acting but they haven't done
the trials and tribulations the acting
classes the courses the dedication like
the previous generation has the suckiest
parts exactly yeah they know and it's
the repetition of the stuff that you
hate the most that makes you really
great yeah like showing up on a dominoes
commercial or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah i feel very
fortunate that i get to see actors like
that because we also got to see um the
man who played the grandfather what's
his name
james wong james [ __ ] wong dude when
he came out i was so happy number one
because he's still alive oh and he just
got a star on the hollywood walk fame
which took way too long by the way james
[ __ ] 90 years old and he's still
memorizing lines and killing it and he's
been like 400 movies how the [ __ ] is he
so sharp
90 years old i guess because he keeps
practicing his art his mind is sharp i
remember him from the seinfeld episode
scifi
i remember him from wayne's world too
yeah he has tia carreras who by the way
was like the hottest asian american in
the 90s but yeah like
he was her dad and then he had a
fight scene with wayne yeah yeah yeah
like bad dubbing
but yeah um did you want to do the
entire review yeah let's just let's go
through the whole film yeah um yeah
we'll do our classic way like uh just
chilling out and we just read the plot
from wikipedia and then we'll just go
through the movie
um
so
the film is separated into three parts
with the names matching the title of the
film part one is everything evelyn wang
is a chinese-american woman who runs a
struggling laundromat with her husband
weymouth
tensions are high due to the laundromat
being audited by the irs additionally
weyman is trying to give evelyn divorce
papers
evelyn's demanding father gong gong has
just arrived from china and evelyn's
daughter joy has been trying to get her
mother to accept her girlfriend becky
so uh this is the opening scene and what
we see is just like chaos pure chaos
like their home reminds me of my parents
home like just cluttered with like [ __ ]
from the store from the business because
they have nowhere to store it they just
put it all over the house
and like there's total chaos what i also
appreciated was um
when when what we call it is konglish
when we speak korean and english but i
don't know what they call it english i
guess so that would be english like
chinese english yeah and they're like
the way
they communicate i really did appreciate
that but it also comes to
kind of um play a gag uh later on on in
the film because it's part of their
miscommunication as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and then um so yeah
we see wayman is
like
kind of a pushover yeah yeah yeah yeah
um i mean uh his characters is kind of
mousy and submissive i think to evelyn
but he's trying to serve her divorce
papers yeah
yeah
and evelyn's character is
pretty hard-nosed
like
very blunt
no tact and such um she doesn't really
seem to
give a [ __ ] about too many things except
for
i mean because she's so distracted by so
many things too she's doing a million
things at once like essentially
her
i mean what i kind of looked at it now
when i after the film i was like
she's the perfect person to go ahead and
try to manage all these multiverses
because that's just her regular life
yeah her regular life is her trying to
balance a thousand [ __ ] things at
once yeah even before the introduction
of the the headpiece that got her into
the multiverse she's trying to deal with
you know her her daughter's gay identity
running the business taking care of the
grandfather doing all this [ __ ] at once
it was already chaos since the beginning
yeah and um
so
with her his their daughter joy
she's running around trying to speak to
her mom about
um inviting her girlfriend
to the
the chinese new year's party right
and like if she brings her what would
their gran her grandfather gong gong
think
and evelyn more or less is kind of
putting it on the shelf because she
wants to just hide it from her father
and not even deal with what he has to
say or think yeah and so she is more or
less motivated by what her father gong
gong thinks yeah and joy is more or less
just trying to open up to her like hey
like
this has to come up now
like she's already out to her mom but
then like you were saying the way she
responds to her being gay is just like
yeah what's the big deal who cares
whatever stop like don't you know i'm
being audited while to her daughter like
this is the most important thing what
you're speaking about right now
yeah and so her mind is all over the
place to the point where joy leaves to
her car
and evelyn tries to run and catch up
with her
she's i have something to tell you and
what does she say
oh she was like uh you have to eat
healthier yeah you're getting fat yeah
but then that just goes to show
she's actually trying to be loving yeah
she doesn't know how that's her way
of saying hey um i care about you is
don't you don't eat healthy and don't
you look fat you know the tie back to
what thing with like what i was talking
about with asian parents is that idea of
being empathetic towards their the way
that they try to express their love and
their language my mom was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's a little
different yeah you know what i mean you
and i we share the same
on my issues yeah
so
in that type of case too it also goes
back to me saying how much i enjoyed
this film how it does it through the
stuff that you see through everyday life
without having to explicitly say it yeah
it wasn't a dialogue where she
where um joy had a random dialogue or a
monologue to herself where she goes
asian parents just don't know how to
communicate the way that they love to me
or they love me yeah they're telling me
that i'm fat and then it goes into a
scene where she calls her fat doesn't
have to be [ __ ] said like that it is
shown it's shown i love it it's like
like you've heard it before you've heard
asian people say it but then
um
yo their acting also portrays it like
how much it hurt her and she just got in
the car and drove away crying
because it's like it's not even the fact
that she called her fat it's just
what she's trying to even tell her mom
is flying over her head like how
important this is to her
and then it cuts to the iris building um
wayman and um
the grandfather and evelyn
are uh going into the irs building right
so while at the irs building for a
meeting with the irs inspector deidre
bob
bobinger i don't think that's her name
yeah uh jamie lee curtis awesome when
she came out oh [ __ ] yeah uh wayman's
personality changes when his body is
briefly taken over by alpha women a
version of women from the alpha universe
or the alpha verse
alpha wayman explains to evelyn that
many parallel universes exist
since every choice made creates a new
universe
the people of the alphabet alpha verse
led by the late alpha evelyn developed
verse jumping technology that allows
people to access the skills memories and
body of their parallel universe
counterparts by fulfilling specific
conditions
the multiverse is being threatened by
jobu to [ __ ] formerly alpha joy
her mind was splintered when alpha
evelyn pushed her to extensively verse
jump jobu tupaki now experiences all
universes at once and can verse jump and
manipulate matter at will
with her god-like power she has created
a black hole
like everything bagel that can
potentially destroy the multiverse
so this is when it gets [ __ ] crazy
and this is where i don't understand
anything yeah this is where i was just
like
i don't get anything that's happening
right now like this is just really
really hyper complicated at this point
so um while at the irs building um
jamie lee curtis's character is is
auditing them and showing them like
symbolically she puts it on a receipt
and puts a big black circle the
revolving circle is a visual theme that
shows up like even at the laundromat
right
and that this circle that spins like um
is a visual thing that keeps popping up
throughout right
and um
so she's saying like i see all the
receipts
right i know where you came from and i
know where it's going right and it
doesn't look good
right
and so she's kind of foreshadowing like
what's coming up with you know what's
going on
um but meanwhile
she can't focus she's not even listening
to her
right because alpha wayman showed her
the idea of of the this multiverse thing
right and she put on these bluetooth
headsets
on her ear to
show her
like the multiverse like how it can be
opened up to her and the first thing she
sees in the elevator
is her life flash before her eyes which
was like an amazing montage for me like
she comes out the vagina and then you
see james wong standing there and the
doctor says i'm sorry it's a girl
this is such a subtle good joke right so
like you know it's it's the idea too if
you guys don't know they have like in
china they also have like this one child
policy thing which i'm not sure if it's
still around but they want a boy to
carry on the name yeah and so there was
an issue too where you'll see a lot of
people who want to adopt kids from asia
specifically china and a lot of them
were girls because they would give up
these girls and they would sometimes
you know
be thrown away yeah it was pretty
[ __ ] bad and we had to hear about
this stuff you know before we did like
missionary trips yeah yeah yeah which
was the same yeah you know
yeah and so um it kind of goes through
her life and like um
i i think they did some of that de-aging
stuff like where
um she and wayman meet and then how her
father disapproves of the relationship
yeah but she goes with him anyways and
follows him to america to a shanty
laundromat and a um
shanty apartment upstairs and then like
wayman is completely positive about
everything but then you can consistently
see that she's not happy with anything
that is unfolding
right
and then
um and so at that point she is being
still being connected
you know into this um
this multiverse through alpha wayman
trying to communicate with her right and
so she gives her instructions
of
um like how to jump
right
but
it's on the back of the divorce papers
right which is what i mean earlier with
their chinglish like this the [ __ ]
writing of this i also predict best
original screenplay the oscars
like how well that they played this gag
of them
talking about two different things but
arguing about it at the same time that
is great [ __ ] writing yeah yeah yeah
yeah and um
so like that's what i mean about the
pacing too you get confused because
they're confused yeah yeah yeah about
two different things and there are two
different women's and neverlands
right
and uh so what she does is have to
imagine something
right
because the idea of like the the
the theoretical physics of the
multiverse is basically anything
anything you've ever imagined or dreamed
has happened yeah in another universe
that's how
big infinity is according to the
multiverse theory yeah right and so he's
telling her hey imagine this do
something weirdly insane this random
thing right and once you do that it
initiates the the connection the jump
and then you hit the button
right
and so that's how she ends up in the
closet where raymond is trying to
explain to her this entire theory but
she can't focus with
her adhd
and that kind of thing like was really
really touched me because like that's
sometimes i feel like that's how i think
if i have to think about my taxes my
mind goes elsewhere my mind is she was
giving me anxiety yeah because of how
she couldn't focus on anything at all
yeah she was
he was not about everything every
anything everywhere it was her brain
that was her brain yeah constantly it
was kind of like allegory throughout the
whole film you know like that's what i'm
saying it was just like the whole
multiverse thing makes sense with her
character because that's how her mind
[ __ ] runs yeah i want this one side
tangent too because i was looking at
trying to read up about what mo the
multiverse theory is and then i went to
like the whole time travel theory and
stuff and then my mind was just
exhausted man this is so much to take in
because there's i'm not sure if you've
if you've read about this but it's like
the idea of how time travel works isn't
how we think it works yeah right and
there was like a few people
uh i don't remember their [ __ ] names
but they were talking about i was
reading this whole uh this whole blog
about it
but it's the idea
that
time what doesn't it matter or really
exist in the way that we think the
moment time travel is created
so from the date to the point where time
travel is created you can't go back
there you can only start from when time
travel was created and then only go from
the future and the future only back to
the point where time travel was created
because you can't go back from before
when it never existed right i was like
oh [ __ ] i didn't even [ __ ] think
about that yeah right that's interesting
i started thinking i started going
through this rabbit hole of that and
then the whole multiverse theory too and
now i'm just like what is life
yeah
and yeah and that's the running theme
about it right his life is that as you
get older and that's prevalent an
evelyn's character herself the cynicism
and nihilism in her is is through her
relationships around her is that the
more and older we get the more we learn
about the universe it's almost
inevitable that we become cynical it's
almost inevitable to become nihilists
and it's hard to
see a positive future because you get
into this existential crisis right and
that's the point because
when he's
telling her like where alpha weighman
comes from this alpha verse that alpha
evelyn who is this awesome great [ __ ]
genius woman like created this
this
universe jumping but she
implemented it onto her daughter joy
right
to um you know learn how to jump but
then she overworked her daughter like
many asian parents do to their own kids
right where to the point she can just
jump anywhere she wants to everywhere
yeah and because joy has received and
seen everything she is now have become
the ultimate god a god and a nihilist
yeah very much like dr manhattan in the
watchman more and more he became you
know dr manhattan
you know and seeing the universe the
more you lose your humanity yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so
what we're seeing is jobu tupac is
[Music]
formerly alpha joy
um
she is
trying to get to
um she already killed alpha evelyn but
she's trying to destroy all the evidence
of all that multiverses yeah
right and so she's
finally trying to get to the eveline we
know in this universe
and
let's see
evelyn is given verse jumping technology
to fight jobu to paki's verse jumping
minions who begin converging in the irs
building evelyn learns of weymouth's
plans to divorce her and discovers other
lives where she made different choices
and flourished such as becoming a kung
fu master and movie star instead of
leaving china with waymon who becomes a
successful businessman
alpha wayman comes to believe that
evelyn as the greatest failure of all
evaluations of the multiverse has the
untapped potential to defeat joe
butupaki
alpha gangang instructs evelyn to kill
joy to hinder job to [ __ ] but evelyn
refuses she decides she must face
djobutupaki by gaining the same powers
as her so she verse jumps repeatedly by
battling jobu to paki's minions and
alpha gong gong soldiers
after the battle alpha wayman is killed
by jobutupaki in the alpha verse and
evelyn's mind overloads this is right
before part two yeah
right
so
this is the part where like it gets
really [ __ ] up and weird because
um
she
out of the um
confusion and their um communication
issues
she punches jamie lee curtis in the face
because she thinks like talking about
fighting is about fighting literal
people she cracked me the [ __ ] up yeah
she straight up socked her right in the
nose yeah and um then alpha wayman has
to come and deal with uh the security
coming in and he eats chapstick yeah and
then that connects him to a universe
where he knows how to do fanny pack kung
fu
which was [ __ ] dope yeah i'm like
holy [ __ ] the five scenes in this were
great too i loved it it's so hong kong
expire inspired yeah and then um
basically from there let's see this is
where it's so [ __ ] hard to get
together
because um
because
joe butupake's minions are chasing after
her
like the
um alpha
jamie lee curtis's character right
um she starts to attack her and then the
information that she gets from the alpha
verse is that she has to confess her
love to deidra
right yeah and she has to be like i love
you i love you to learn how to do kung
fu right to do something completely
out of the ordinary
right but then it also kind of points
back towards how
uh
it's in the same universe they love each
other where they have these hot dog
fingers
right yeah yeah this movie gets so
random when it accesses
multiverse that they're how connected
they get they become more and more it
seems so [ __ ] random yeah but then
they all come together in the mo this is
why i say
they deserve an editing oscar um
so
um it's only in the universe where she
loves her is where she also has these um
hot dog fingers but in that hot dog
fingers universe is the reason why
they're very proficient at using their
feet and toes
[Laughter]
so there's so many crazy [ __ ] fight
scenes where um she also when she has to
fight
she learns how to use like hand knives
and stuff because there's another
universe where she's like a japanese
teppanyaki yeah
yeah
um yeah and so it goes [ __ ] crazy and
wild and by the way all of this is
happening in the the same irs building
there's oh that's right what's happening
that you don't realize that this movie
really only has three locations yeah
yeah yeah the laundromat the apartment
and the irs building and the rest is the
green screen
yeah like they got their [ __ ] money's
worth out of this movie i mean the
really cool thing about that too is like
you'll you know
just as i don't know if it's really
symbolic of it but you kind of see it
towards like the end of the film which
you could probably touch on later is
when you see
this this movie also has like a really
good
moral to the story right because when
you're seeing with the whole multiverse
thing
where she's
allocating all these weird skills
because of
some type of oddity that happened in
this other multiverse character of her
right which kind of goes with the idea
of like everything happens for a reason
yeah right because it's like well this
person who has hot dog fingers well
guess what because they're hot dog they
can't use it they're really good with
their feet
it was like i love how they kind of
homaged 2001 a space odyssey like a
classic sci-fi film worth their apes and
the hot dog finger ape killed the
regular humanoid
and that's why in this universe there's
[ __ ] hot dog people yeah like it's so
crazy and absurd it's the most absurd
movie i've seen i just don't understand
where the writing came from it was
almost like when i was watching it
remind me of rick and morty yeah where i
don't understand how they wrote this
episode yeah and how it makes sense
that's what i mean like i
the
someone who used to write for ricky
moore i remember his name he wrote
doctor strange multiverse of madness oh
no spoilers but when you watch it it
feels like a rick and morty episode oh
really yeah
and that [ __ ] must be a crazy
human being then because i don't
understand how you think of [ __ ] like
that yeah even if i tried if i sat in
this room for let's say a month straight
and somebody says you need to write a
multiverse script that makes sense
i would
and then if you don't you're dead i'd
just be dead i can't do it it's
literally anything is possible yeah
anything you imagine is
has happened in another another
multiverse wherever you go
see like every single choice you've ever
made
you know it creates another multiverse
this is the whole idea of schrodinger's
cat
and that's another [ __ ] mind-blowing
paradox that i don't want to get into
but if you youtube it
the idea is every decision you've ever
made like splits off into another
multiverse yeah yeah yeah and there's
like rick and morty episodes of that as
well
you know and that's basically what neo
is we were talking about like every
decision ever made in the in the matrix
was already decided for it yeah yeah it
was very and that is the combination the
code which is neo
and so um this movie is almost like the
matrix because in the matrix you can do
whatever you want and feel like but then
the idea here is
within all of us too like
um you you go and look back
in through your whole history and you
think about the decisions you made and
where would you be what would happen if
that was the case
right
like we've all thought those things
right yeah and the
multiverse theory is yeah it whatever
you've imagined has happened really just
which is just crazy to think about
because there are times too when i was
younger i would think like what if i
didn't do this
how different would my life have been
right what if i
um
i did get into the university that i
wanted to go into would i have ended up
on youtube when i ended up pursuing
comedy yeah right and because one of the
biggest like trajectory shifts in my
life was when i didn't get into the
college i wanted to and i had to go
somewhere else yeah and it molded this
this this part of my life that would
have never existed yeah you know
so
and that's the one one important part is
that
when she learns kung fu
it's because she never left with waymon
to america
right and so she becomes a [ __ ] kung
fu movie star
you know with a shifu and everything
like
um
and
wayman does his own thing and he becomes
a successful businessman right and then
when she snaps out of it
she's like i just saw my life without my
husband and it was amazing i need to
tell him
yeah so and then like like i said the
way they communicate is so like manifest
it's how we our parents speak to us
everything is a matter of fact there's
no emotions involved yeah this is what
it is alpha wayman is telling evelyn
like because you're such a failure you
have the most potential as anyone in the
entire multiverse
that's so funny that's exactly how asian
parents thought yeah when my mom with
the whole photos thing and she goes in
her mind she was like i wanted more
photos
so i'm gonna ask him why he was so cheap
and didn't get more photos yeah not even
in that in her mind she goes what's so
wrong what's wrong about this it's not a
her problem it's your problem yeah is it
my problem dude
holy [ __ ] dude that's so [ __ ] funny
so
yeah in the process i believe wayman
gets
stabbed right
and then the
and that's where that multiverse ends i
believe right because at this point
joy becomes this amazing like she can
start multi-jumping or whatever yeah i
forgot what it was called verse jumping
and um
the credits roll
oh yeah yeah yeah
the credits roll and then oh we're in
the the multiverse where she's you know
essentially michelle yo herself right
but she's this big movie star
and then it turns into a wanker y film
and they have this amazing dialogue in
the alley when they try to get away
right
and then because
that is a
evelyn is the evelyn that is aware that
she is multi-jumping um first jumping i
mean
that
um they get into this conversation about
like she said what she was gonna say
like
you know what what did you want
you know you you you wish that i ran
away with you you know to america and
then we just ran some shanty laundromat
and live in an apartment
right and then he gets offended
he speaks back and he's like maybe i
just i want to
live in a small apartment in rhonda
laundromat with you
right because that is the love he's
trying to express but then the love that
evelyn can't or doesn't understand
yeah yeah
your life would have been better without
me and my life would have been better
without you yeah everything is so
factual a matter of fact well you know
also goes into the idea of like what the
definition of like happiness is
right because in her mind she's looking
at it as like
incremental steps to success right which
you see on the exterior i am a movie
star you're a successful businessman
we're way happier yeah but his that that
current universe wayman is more like no
my version of happiness was just being
with you it didn't matter where it
doesn't matter right so how she defined
is that miscommunication thing they
they're speaking two different [ __ ]
languages and she doesn't get it you
know
so before uh we jump into part two of
everywhere i want to talk about that
fight scene where they get the [ __ ]
butt plugs
[Laughter]
it's because they they had to access
some other part of their
burst jumping to do
dildo kung fu
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] hilarious dude
yeah i'm like why the [ __ ] and how this
is just so stupid and funny dude yeah i
mean and
it is so wild that you also just like
what a good way to make us not look away
like i can't not watch this bizarre [ __ ]
happening
anything is possible the multiverse
so part two everywhere
evelyn's mind splinters and she
discovers other bizarre universes
including one in which humans have hot
dogs for fingers and she is in a
romantic relationship with deidre
and the drug is and another where she
works online
alongside a teppanyaki chef who is
secretly puppeteered by
ratatouille like cocoon
a raccoon she learns that jobutupaki
created the everything bagel not to
destroy everything but to destroy
herself
and has been searching for an eveline
who can understand her
jobu to [ __ ] feels that because there
are so many vast universes and unending
chaos
nothing truly matters
this was touching upon her analysis when
she brings her to the
that everything bagel
right and it's shown that yes she's
just trying to find the eveline that
understands her
and
that's the wild part across all the
the multiverses is that evelyn is still
evelyn
yeah yeah yeah character and herself
where
she has no tact
she doesn't have
great expressions of love at all and
this is why more and more joy her
daughter becomes more of a nihilist and
actually wants to trigger morning commit
suicide yeah yeah
and
i don't know a lot of asian-american
kids we i mean we it's something we do
talk about because you just came back
from korea
korean number one suicide yeah you know
um it's a thing that we do
like and should have to talk about
right and when it comes to talking about
these subjects with our parents
a lot
it flies over their heads yeah they
really don't understand depression
um in the sense that we know it um here
in america right yeah and this movie
portrays that
like right in your face yeah and you
know it's like how i see it too is also
the idea of where i talk about the kids
who
don't see empathy in terms of like what
their parents experienced you know
because there's a certain level too
where
you know
you're just not going to get that out of
your parents yeah just because they
didn't have the emotional tools that you
were equipped with
and it's almost unfair to expect them to
understand you to that certain extent
i only started realizing that i could
just i expect them to do their best and
that's all that i can expect from them
because if if that's the case then i'm
going to be holding my breath until i
pass out it's just not going to happen
you know like like my mom being an
[ __ ]
like i have i go through thought process
of is this a generational thing is this
because of this it's like no
you're a [ __ ]
i go you're gonna have to stop that [ __ ]
and the reason why i have to stop her
doing that is because she also has to
understand that listen when i have kids
you can't talk to my kids that way yeah
you know so you're gonna have to learn
through me that this is not how you
communicate right you could communicate
like that to our dad and to your friends
but you can't do that with me and then
you set those boundaries you know the
idea between like um joy trying to find
this this mom who understands her it's
it's to me was kind of like you're not
going to find that because your mom does
understand you she just doesn't know how
to express herself yeah it's not a youth
it's not a youth thing at all
whether she hates or dislikes you she
still loves you she just she's not she
doesn't have the tools to deal with her
own emotions with the idea that her
daughter is gay
you know so her her annihilation is
there's a fallacy in her logic it's like
i'm looking for this perfect mom or this
mom who could understand me every one of
those moms that you met understood you
they just don't know how to express it
you know
[Music]
and and um it also touches on when we
meet alpha gong gong
that
um where evelyn gets this from is from
her father that
and it's consistently expressed through
him his
disappointment in her
and like even to the point where she is
wants to prove him wrong
right and she
also have these parental issues with
their own father which is then being
passed down
to her own daughter yeah right and so we
see that alpha
you know gong gong is the true
antagonist in a sense
by how he created evelyn
and um the other part like being like
you know we were talking about like we
mentioned this joke like my uh my
friend's mom calling
doritos todori yeah right and the thing
is the multiverse theory there's a
universe where there's a
nacho snack called totoris
it exists somewhere else yeah yeah yeah
yeah because evelyn gets confused about
uh ratatouille and she calls it rakakui
yeah right i mean she's so adorable and
cute like when she acts she's like i i
also hope and predict that she gets a
best leading actress nomination at the
oscars for this and just to kind of like
bigger up a little bit do you have an
idea how hard it is to perform and act
that well in a language that's your
second language yeah that she learned
and like
she literally i remember watching her
she couldn't speak any english at all
and then also she does all of the
[ __ ] kung fu yeah in it like she
knows how to do it she better win every
[ __ ] award out there yeah because it
is so [ __ ] hard to do that and it
took time
by the way side side convo too and i
just want to bring this up because it
just struck me in the head it had
nothing to do with this movie
i really really [ __ ] dislike asian
people
okay okay and then finish your sentence
[Laughter]
and that wraps up this episode
i really disliked our asian people when
you guys gave [ __ ] ethan hawk [ __ ]
for not being able to speak mandarin
fluently in [ __ ] um
uh moonlight moon night yeah i thought
that was [ __ ] dumb number one
how much time did he have yeah to learn
a [ __ ] tonal language and a language
as hard as [ __ ] mandarin yeah the
audacity it was like two lines
it was like a few [ __ ] lines you know
and then people were going in on him
like
dude why don't you do better try harder
like that's not fair
number one that's not fair yeah number
two do you have any idea like the
journey it took for any asian american
actors or writers to even get these
people to be like
oh like did you think ethan hawk was
going to be like oh i [ __ ] learned it
enough
you know this is good enough yeah like
no ethan hawk wasn't doing that he was
trying his [ __ ] best to speak a tonal
language that he's never tried before
fluently and the idea that there was his
random crusade i don't know who the [ __ ]
started that [ __ ] where they were just
like [ __ ] on him for it that's the
twitter verse yeah it's the most
ridiculous thing like the i because
because let's just do it the reverse way
right hey you know what i'm writing an
article tomorrow
saying jackie chan is a piece of [ __ ]
for [ __ ] up the english language
hey you did 30 movies like in america
and you still can't speak english
fluently yeah what the [ __ ] try harder
why don't you have a better english
tutor yeah i mean there's there's like a
real reason to be upset and others like
just to like yo give it give it a rest
that's what i'm saying it's like even
when people because the idea of
inclusivity
is not hey [ __ ] you we're important the
idea of inclusivity is say all of our
stories are important let's try to be a
better better to each other yeah right
let's try and express our personal
stories and try
it's not
you didn't do it perfect [ __ ] which is
so asian yeah
yeah you are not asian enough
you know to to speak another language or
something i don't i don't [ __ ] know
it's just like not to our standard like
that's not art that is like nationalism
exactly
what what the hell these [ __ ] c plus
[ __ ] chinese huh yeah like they were
so mad like whoever who if you were one
of those people go [ __ ] yourself dude
because you are you are the exact
opposite of progress you're the exact
opposite of inclusivity when you have
big major name actors who are trying
yeah right and it's not going to be
perfect because i would love for you to
look go ahead and learn i don't know
[ __ ]
i don't know check or some [ __ ] you know
or try to learn [ __ ] russian in a
matter of like i don't know two months
and do it fluently do it right but also
you only get three lines of that
language
right and the rest you have to memorize
like a thousand lines there's eight
episodes of this [ __ ] that he's in too
and he had three lines in mandarin like
give him a [ __ ] break exactly i'm
sure he had the other important
dialogues that he had to memorize as a
korean american if i could watch all
seasons of lost and listen to daniel day
kim's terrible glass career yeah right
and by the way he is korean and he
couldn't [ __ ] speak the language to
save his [ __ ] life
right
[Laughter]
i think we can give ethan hawk a [ __ ]
pass yeah right like come on man that
[ __ ] was so obnoxious yeah i hated
reading that [ __ ] and it speaks to joy's
character too because she can't speak
chinese yeah right and that's where the
the
many many running things of
miscommunication in this film it's part
of the chaos
right and so it gets towards let's see
as we move on
in other universes the wangs are about
to lose the laundromat due to tax errors
and businessman wayman rejects movie
star evelyn after decades apart evelyn
is nearly swayed by joe butupaki's cause
and stabs her universe's women she
almost joins jobu to [ __ ] in entering
the bagel but
stops when she hears weymon's call to be
kind and have hope
evelyn defeats alpha gangang and
jobutupaki's fighters by using her
multiverse knowledge
to find what is hurting each of them and
gives them happiness
evelyn reaches joba to [ __ ] and tells
her that she is not alone and that
evelyn will always choose to be with her
despite everywhere she
everywhere else she could be
meanwhile in parallel universes evelyn
confronts gong gong and reconciles with
waymon and joy and wayman convinces
deidre to let the wings redo their taxes
joe butupaki initially rejects evelyn
but returns to her and they embrace
so
the
the craziness of what happens like
they're fighting on that staircase right
back at the irs building and she brings
the everything bagel in
where she is on her way
to kill herself
that's what she wants yeah and gangnam
wants that to happen yeah
that's his goal like the whole idea is
to kill joe butaki
right and grandfather is like yeah kill
that whatever that she is or whatever in
this
multiverse
you know and
and that's
the the darkest part about this this
movie is how we feel like this kind of
stuff is fed to us from our family yeah
right and so evelyn is going up there
trying to save her
and all these minions they come from
different universes and they fight them
and like
um
and it was finally coming to pass like
uh how we started this uh review when
the running theme really being because
there's so much miscommunication there's
so much confusion there's so much chaos
that wayman tells her to stop and take
the time and have a conversation
and talk about it and understand each
other
you know
and so
evelyn's idea of that
it becomes that like yeah
to be kind
right and that brings
that kindness brings this reconciliation
because
in the typing yaki universe she's
beefing with harry sham
but he's only so great at what he does
because of the raccoon yeah
yeah right and like and so he ex she
exposes the raccoon and then the animal
control comes and takes this raccoon
away and it's some of the most visual
hilarious things this puppet raccoon is
like yeah
like don't forget me every shot junior's
balling his eyes out cuz he lost his
raccoon
you know and while that's happening
all the these other things are happening
in the other multiverses where they are
losing you know um like like um
wayman rejecting evelyn and such things
where like these bad terrible things
happen
but how evelyn responds is with kindness
right yeah and then that
and it starts showing it starts
connecting
how like when she uses kindness it
reconciles her relationship with deidre
in the hot dog hand world
you know when she uses kindness once
again um she she reconciles you know um
with harry shum jr and then they run
after to catch
the [ __ ] wreck
and
she's on his head like pulling his hair
the dumbest thing ever dude
you know what you know what it reminded
me of and i'm not sure if you agree with
this like is this just a high budget
kung fu hustle
yeah
dude it's so crazy it's just like kung
fu hustle dude i'm like this is a kung
fu hustle movie i don't even think it's
high budget it's just that uh visual
effects that on your home computer has
come a long long way that they made it
look good
you know um this this whole movie
there's so much to applaud and there's
so much we're definitely missing because
there's so [ __ ] much that's happening
yeah it definitely it has like that that
that hong kong
like
humor yeah the it's like chinese humor
very slapstick you know mixed with like
uh the
the zucker brothers movies like airplane
naked guns yeah yeah yeah yeah
like those films those films are like
dead now like that raccoon stuff just
reminded me of kung fu hustle where
there was that scene where they were he
um
i forgot he he just started having like
those looney tune legs and he was like
i was like oh this reminds me of that or
just like that type of humor and kung fu
hustle where
he was supposed to take the knife and
throw it and he stabs him and he goes he
pulls it out and he goes down so he puts
it right down
just like stupid steven child [ __ ] dude
yeah this literally took the best of
so much of what like cinema like has to
offer and they put it like crammed it in
and this is why i mean like it deserves
best oscar because it works yeah it's so
fast that the most important part
and who [ __ ] knew that i would start
crying
watching two rocks talk yeah
that was the most emotionally engaging
scene
i'd seen in a film and it's two rocks
communicating like with subtitles yeah
right where they end up in a universe
where life isn't possible
you know um or but then like so they end
up as just these rocks right
and
it's
it's so engaging in the way they
actually take a take time to stop and
communicate
and it made it simple
instead of throwing them in another
multiverse where they are actually
talking to each other
somehow it became so much more engaging
to see two rocks with subtitles slow it
down no music make it quiet
it was it was [ __ ] awesome i don't
know what to say i'm just mind blown how
amazing that is yeah i mean this is
because everything
led up to that point to where it would
matter you know and once again it goes
to the point of great writing emotional
cues and these these monologues or these
deep conversations where it kind of like
um basically combines everything that
you were feeling
um to be to this point only matters if
you set it up correctly
if you don't set it up those scenes
don't matter because that scene alone
without everything that happened before
the the masterful way of just how they
combine all these multiverse like the
chaos the the character development then
this matters yeah right and that's what
that's what i'm saying like this film
was just the writing is so good yeah
it's so [ __ ] good and i always like
films that do this where it's just it
kind of hits you hard and
in the ways that you expected it but you
didn't expect yeah you know it's like oh
i expected there to be an emotional hit
to this but not like this not like this
two rocks yeah oh my god why is it
better that it was two rocks than there
was them having an emotional seat maybe
inside the laundromat yeah even the
ridiculousness of how she jumps off the
ledge as a rock and then evelyn jumps in
after her with the googly eyes yeah i
started [ __ ] tearing up i'm like no
don't do it it's a rock yeah you know
but then it was representing all across
the universe of of how
with joba tupac kills herself then all
the joys die yeah you know and she was
just going to destroy herself
and then it
what it needed was like for the family
to
have to come together in an
understanding of like let's just be kind
and talk about this because it's very
important to understand that the the
thickness of the junk in chaos is still
there but how you accept it and how you
respond to it either with cynicism and
nihilism or with kindness and
understanding and take the time to stop
and talk and be quiet yeah all the
madness of everything and this movie
visually did it they showed it
yeah
um yeah i i i
think this is probably one of the best
movies of the year for me
and like but one of the other important
parts
and this is complete nihilism and this
is a
another trigger morning because this is
dark path is
evelyn stands up to her father gong gong
finally says and holds
their the kid's hands
and tells her like
this
is joy's girlfriend
right
and like this is who we are and then
like brings it out to congo because that
was the problem in the first half of the
movie right
but what we see
is joy get upset and walk away
right
which is this
a
very sad and deep part of cynicism and
nihilism where
you're still caught up in the fact that
i'm gay yeah and that's not even what
it's about anymore yeah right it's like
you still don't understand me yet you
don't get it
right and so for that last
bit of um
uh dialogue they have in the parking lot
where they have to do their best to try
to be just kind and patient with each
other and give each other the time you
know and not lose hope not give up on
everything don't let it die just yet
you know yeah
that it's still ongoing it's gonna keep
going
you know but if you are kind and
understanding you know that you can find
a common area right
which is hard for people like us to do
because i also relate to evelyn in a way
where sometimes i don't have tact and i
say some mean [ __ ] i mean sure you
understand too story of my life bro
i hate asian people yeah
let me rephrase that
i hate it when asian people do this yeah
and
but it shows that for someone like
evelyn that kindness is an exercise yeah
you have to practice it
you know it takes a big step
but
you look at all the multiverses that she
went through and all the stupid wacky
crazy [ __ ] she had to do to access a
universe where she knows how to do kung
fu
all across the universes they
the act of kindness
the act of kindness was the
that random act the weird insane thing
yeah that connected
all the other evidence to each other
yeah you know where they all
practice and learn kindness that there
are universes
where even knowing the deepest like
shadiest part of yourself
like if you imagine that you're kind
you're kind out there
but you can do that right here right now
too yeah that's the practice do you have
to access the multiverse to be kind
yeah yeah yeah but no that is a power
that all of us have you know it doesn't
have to be [ __ ] hot dogs special toe
kung fu
you know
i mean that's what i'm saying this film
was so good like in terms of hitting
that
that moral button
really well there's just so many layers
to it talks about the you know the asian
family dynamic which even even goes
broader to just general family dynamics
alone where there's people in a family
that doesn't know how to express
themselves you know it happens a lot
with people not just asian families just
a lot of immigrant families because
there's
first generation
1.5 and then two right and then
obviously a stuff after that but it
starts to get really whitewashed after
that not in a negative way but that
american watch i would say
but
my parents and i used to have a lot of
issues and you know when we were arguing
earlier my mom pissed me off because she
was like oh it's because you don't
understand korean i was like no i
understand kareem pretty well you
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's just saying like
you got scammed by koreans yeah i was
like i understand and she what was i
saying i repeated it back to her right
in korean she goes
okay maybe you do understand and i'm
like i do understand i'm telling you
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] she can't lose
this fight yeah she just can't lose it
she wants to chalk it up to oh you're
right and i'm right no no no you're
wrong and you're wrong that's it yeah
either you apologize or we're not moving
from this right
and so my mom had to not she didn't
apologize of course but she had she just
kind of stayed quiet which usually means
she knows she's wrong so it's like but
there's like this weird language barrier
too where i see it a lot in my personal
family members who don't speak korean at
all and every time i talk to the parent
i talk to them it's two different
stories and it's like oh you go you guys
just don't speak each other's [ __ ]
languages that's why you guys don't
understand each other yeah and it's
impossible and it's really hard for like
for example when um you know i said
years ago one of my biggest requirements
were for whoever i'm with whether
they're black white mexican [ __ ]
whatever right vietnamese chinese
doesn't matter
they have to learn how to speak korean
and
for
there was a girl that i dated um
we've split up because of this and
honestly if if this did if this wasn't
the defining fact i probably would have
stayed with her um pending from how it
was going and we probably would have
gotten married
but she refused to learn how to speak
korean
and then she we had a conversation where
she said
hey she goes well i think it's unfair
that you want me to learn how to you
know speak korean she goes would you
learn how to speak vietnamese i was i
was already taking me to meet classes i
was like yeah i'm doing it right now
yeah
right and she's quiet didn't know what
to say she goes i just don't want to do
it i was like well we're done then
because if i'm willing to put in the
effort to go ahead and because i told
her family is a very important thing and
for her her argument was there's plenty
of people who don't speak the language
and they get married i was like but
do you know their family dynamic because
i do
they don't know they can't speak to the
parents they just go are you hungry you
want
they can't even eat the same food
exactly yeah i was like there's there's
communication is so [ __ ] important
beyond did you poop eat [ __ ] are you
hungry yeah right because the moment you
could talk to them or even understand
them at that point you get to understand
who they are you get to know them as a
person you get to see their life as a
teenager because of how they describe
these stories to you
it is a huge part of the reason why
there's a huge family dynamic issue with
a lot of immigrant parents and their
kids because the kids don't know the
language and they don't and because they
don't know the language they don't
understand the [ __ ] culture and so
it's always like this
just
explosions and [ __ ] gunfire all the
time yeah they just never see eye to eye
and you see that in like this show too
in this show the movie and it's very
representative of that like i [ __ ]
loved yeah um and to bring it back why
uh part of our original
or before we started talking about this
movie how we segwayed was the fact that
after all these shootings and national
tragedies that keep happening there's
always
becomes a two-sided argument
you know
and um i know it's hard like i i am not
like the kind of person that subscribes
to kindness
and it's an exercise like something i
have to do my best to do
right and like by watching this movie
too like like i said like these abortion
issues these racial issues these
shootings they will keep happening and
they'll keep going on as of right now
but then
as soon as we like we can actually learn
to communicate take time
be quiet
listen understand and talk you know like
wayman's character yeah like is the way
we can find like a conclusion or a
compromise you know where we can live
together without [ __ ] trying to kill
each other yeah and i think a lot of us
too were so quick to anger and then
quick to kind of like jump into our
emotions first without assessing a
situation it you know it always it tends
to make things a lot worse like i
remember in k-town one time like and
this kind of has something to do with it
but just like not being able to control
those emotions assess what's going on
can lead to very bad things um not even
just on a personal skill like you can
[ __ ] get killed for [ __ ] like that
like i was in k-town and um
[Music]
there was this dude
that was i don't know i don't remember
it's been so long but it was like an
altercation between this guy and this
other guy right well the other guy i
knew who was in that group
and in that group was was a hyung of
mine right and i'm like
these [ __ ] are affiliated then
because he's he's still gangbangs of his
day and i'm like oh
i'm looking at this guy over here i'm
like
you're gonna die tonight and that's all
i thought right because in his mind he's
looking at this person either way the
altercation was small it could have been
squashed by moving on or whatever but
they started getting each other's face
and you could see the other guy he's not
even yelling he's just staring at him
and i look over and i see the hyung and
i'm walking over i was like hold on let
me handle this i walk over i was like
hey guys it's chill it's all good right
we're just here having a good time
whatever what not and you know obviously
the dude is still [ __ ] pissed the
other guy's a little drunk and he's
mouthing off a little bit but he doesn't
know he keeps it up he's literally going
to die yeah like he he will [ __ ] these
guys don't give a [ __ ] they've all been
to prison they'll go to prison again and
so i'm just sitting there just like okay
whatever talking to them put take them
aside whatever i buy their table of
drinks i went to the you know the hung i
bought their whole table a couple
pitches of beer went over them bought
him a picture of a beer walked over to
him i was like hey you have to leave and
he's like why i was like all those guys
are strapped they're gonna [ __ ] kill
you
and and first he's like what are they
gonna do blah blah blah blah and
literally you see these dudes that had
their hand on their waist and they're
looking at me i was like you need to
leave now i was like i squashed it i'm
playing all cool like i [ __ ] know you
i told them that you guys are my friends
you're not my friends you need to
[ __ ] leave yeah and then this guy his
two buddies and like two girls got up
and they [ __ ] left but they would
have [ __ ] died they literally would
have died yeah and they were [ __ ]
pissed and the only reason why they said
because i told him that they were my
friends yeah so in that type of
situation too like imagine if he that
individual right there would have just
thought twice you know and would have
squashed his whole [ __ ] because even if
you looked at the guy it was like listen
you already know you're not gonna [ __ ]
this guy up well in this universe that
you experienced you walked away yeah
there are other universes where that guy
died exactly and i think about moments
like that like imagine what would have
happened if i wasn't there yeah what if
i didn't say like oh that's my homie
he's a little drunk yeah and i walked
over bottom of picture bears like unique
at the [ __ ] out yeah
literally they were gonna kill him i
mean you have examples and stories of
where you were in the middle of a
conflict and the only other choice you
could make is just to be kind
and have just extreme love you have
examples of that where you just went the
other way you were like you know what
[ __ ] this like i mean i've definitely
done this like later on in life where
you know
when i was younger if we were at a bar
situation and somebody was being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] i would just match that
energy yeah right and then we would see
what would happen i'm not saying i got
into fights or anything but we would
yell at each other or if it did get into
a fight it would have been a bar fight
yeah now
i'm more like
okay this person's drunk
this is not who they are or if this is
who they are like now like this then
they're going through some other [ __ ] so
then like for example
one time i was at a bar and
this guy was clearly [ __ ] drunk
because
i was talking to the bartender who's a
girl it's her job to serve me drinks
yeah but that was his girlfriend and
this whole comes up to me and he's just
like why don't you just get your [ __ ]
drink to stop hitting on my [ __ ]
girlfriend and i'm like
she's a bartender
you know hurry up buddy you know
she's like rolling her eyes she's like
i'm so sorry he's drunk at that point i
chose like kindness right but i chose
kindness in a weird in a different way i
was like hey listen dude
you're a little drunk
i'm gay
i don't even like women yeah oh my bad
bro i was like i'm kidding i'm not gay
but you see what i'm saying like this is
not a big deal like like she's a
bartender i'm just ordering a drink man
you're good dude so you want me to get
you a drink i'll buy you drinks my bad
if i hurt your feelings yeah and he goes
uh just we're having a good time and his
attitude flipped like that yeah and so
yeah it's true like kindness and this is
just one example of many right it's it's
disarming yeah because the whole idea of
this
this film is that these people keep
trying to
come up with special powers to defend
themselves or go on the offensive and
deal with the conflict all throughout
this movie right that's the idea but the
main point being but like from this jump
from the start you know if you came to
an understanding if you defused it if
you disarmed it
you know that you can get through some
of these things like you can have the
outcome that you might be looking for
yeah right like you're not gonna win it
a lot of times by having to you know
have conflict over it many times you
know it just destroys many things
there's going to be a loser
have you ever done that [ __ ] where
you're in a car and then somebody i
don't know they think that either they
cut you off they roll down their window
i got this for this guy
i do this a lot it hasn't happened in a
while because i don't really drive
around as much as i used to but when i
was in cape town in l.a i had to do this
all the time where somebody would just
drive up next to me they would roll down
the window and i would roll down my
window first i'll go i'm so sorry yeah
it's cool they just drive the [ __ ] off
because what they want to do is call me
a [ __ ] she pissed me out but if you go
i am so sorry
it disarms them right you know unless
that idea of kindness goes a lot
it goes a lot more longer or a long way
than [ __ ] anger or hate does right
and you know what are they going to say
to me at that point are you going to be
that [ __ ] that after somebody
apologizes profusely you're still going
to curse me out
probably not
i've i've
i think i've told this story before um
like when
i went back home for like the first
month
i went to safeway um to buy some [ __ ]
and then uh i heard this chinese yellow
lady oh that's right screaming at people
right and then in my head i was like oh
[ __ ] they have a chinese person working
here
uh because they have like a chinese deli
like oh there's just some white lady
with this really good chinese accent she
was really good at it
but
my once i saw that it was a white lady
doing this because she was like if you
want general assault then it's going to
be 5 39 like like that
but she was doing way better than me
and yeah my instinct though because of
my hair triggers with racism is
to have a problem with it and to have
conflict
so i walked up to her and then i said
do you talk like this all the time or
are you just making a joke you know
because if you talk like this all the
time that's your accent i can't talk
about that right
um
but then she went off on the
i have freedom of speech it's my first
amendment right or whatever and then i'm
like that's cool
but like
you're not at home you're at safeway
yeah
you're doing this super loud like that's
for one that's just not even
professional like you're wearing a
safeway t-shirt yeah you know with your
name tag on it you know and then she was
like oh my gosh it's you know like
this and that you're so sensitive in the
first amendment and
i was like okay whatever right my idea
of defusing was walking away yeah right
but then she started screaming louder as
i was walking away she was like
i don't hate anybody i love everyone i
love him and then i love that person and
she goes i could even love you too
so i turned around and i walked up to
her
and then
i said
um can i give you a hug yeah and she
goes yes
and we just embraced in the middle of
safeway and she was just crying in my
arms and then i just had to say
you know you're not a racist and i love
you too yeah you know and she was like
i'm sorry i'm sorry i i didn't know that
it was offend you i didn't i've never
been in this position like me so sorry
i honey you're feeling i don't want
trouble
you're still doing
[Laughter]
sometimes i don't know if i want to get
back into it but like you know we grew
up church boys yeah both in ministry
we're in leadership um
but we also know like this
this part of how we the character of god
is that the kindness of the lord is what
brings us to repentance yeah yeah right
but it's not just that it's it's it's
the corners that's one of the
cornerstones of the gospel
really if you
you know bring god's love quote unquote
through you being that vessel you know
and then you show kindness
right
it disarms for sure it brings other
people to a place where they can start
quote-unquote repenting where this lady
it brought her to finally say sorry and
know she was wrong just because
i brought kindness this is something i
probably won't ever do again i just
didn't know in that moment i was like
[ __ ] it let's hug it out yeah right
and
my god it works the crazy thing is i
remember why i remember it is because it
was martin luther king day
i was like this is like an mlk miracle
yeah
you said mark you had the kid hovering
behind you
you did it my child he's super proud of
me yeah like he's [ __ ] simba's dad
just in the clouds
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's your dad and he's like you should
have punched her in the page
[Laughter]
bring back
you are such a [ __ ]
that was good
but i mean you and i and a lot of asian
americans because we have parents like
evelyn we have parents like a ganga and
all we know is this hard-nosed [ __ ]
no tact no emotional response
we have to learn this [ __ ] and i think
that's why this movie hits us because as
asian americans we joke so much about
our emotional trauma but then when we
see something like this and we know oh
[ __ ] we have a hard time being kind to
one another yeah
what happened in anaheim let's say yeah
yeah yeah yeah right that's the only
criticism is like the first way and they
they kind of like use criticism as a way
to say if i didn't care about you i
wouldn't criticize you like or you could
just be nice yeah
well that's another problem i know a lot
of people thought it was super corny
that the answer of this movie is be nice
but that's not really it's be kind like
being nice is a little different than
choosing to have a kind heart yeah yeah
yeah cause niceness is you know that's
how you end up with people like nice
guys right yeah yeah yeah like um it's
almost transactional we're not asking
for that it's the kindness is something
like grace going back to the
christianity stuff
but like is that corny they don't
deserve it it's like what you put out in
the universe is what you get back yeah
right and clearly for them you know
being hyper critical and unloving and
just being very rude or trying to like
hyper correct behavior through ignoring
things wasn't really [ __ ] working
yeah what's the opposite try kindness
yeah and it does work pretty [ __ ]
well you know i'm learning this in my
life because i mean i've already
expressed how much i i'm not a christian
or don't go to church anymore i
experienced a lot of resentment because
of that um i mean i literally on this
podcast called out samuck and said wild
[ __ ] but um yeah i i had to
that was my ultimate nihilism about it
right but i'm
through this movie crazy enough
and um other therapies and such i'm i'm
learning like how
like kindness and communication like
goes a long way
shanghi was a good movie guys
[Laughter]
now you're just being nice
i loved it so much one thing i do want
to say though is why this stands out
from shanghai
is
um like this had all of the formula of a
marvel movie right
it's rated r
um and everything [ __ ] worked out
um like shanxi has the mulan problem how
it's a disney movie made for the chinese
government not the people yeah yeah yeah
yeah um but this was an asian american
film everything everywhere all at once
was an
asian-american film for sure
yeah it wasn't like hey let's go off to
china and like
make the chinese government happy make
the chinese you know history traditions
and all that make it a propaganda film
you know while there's nothing wrong
with that it doesn't actually serve the
audience yeah what does it do it's just
the cash grab yeah so so you can get
approval
you know to play in china so then you
can get you know millions and hundreds
of billions of dollars yeah
whatever guys [ __ ] it yeah but in the
day shanghai didn't even end up playing
in china yeah so it's like you didn't
even need to suck up to this to the
government over there you know yeah
maybe i'll try watching the movie again
for the fourth time and maybe i'll see
maybe i can be kind
i actually you know what i take that
back we were pretty kind about it
we were pretty [ __ ] kind yeah we said
nice things and then we talked about
what we didn't like yeah yeah no no like
i i people i don't we don't hate it we
just reviewed it we reviewed it we
dissected it yeah like sorry like we
have opinions like strongly about it
listen there are way worse film than
that like i was just telling ed i
watched the birds of prey and i and it
was and i was on a plane for like 17
hours and it was hard to get through
that [ __ ] film
it was really really [ __ ] hard from
the fight choreography to the
cinematography and the shitty thing was
that was a i think the director was a
female asian director is that right yeah
and i think it like that
i mean she kind of put it to like like
the studios kind of [ __ ] me over on
this which i do probably agree with
because everybody knows that about these
major hollywood films warner brothers in
particular they they get metal their
fingers and everything yeah the dc films
yeah and so it's just it kind of sucks
because i think she went from something
small into this huge budget film which
was supposed to be her big break
but at the same time it's like i i don't
think a big break for a new director
should ever be a marvel or dc film
there's too much hands in it right you
know like you're never gonna get to put
your creative spin on it the way that
you 100 want it to because so many
people have their money and hands in it
yeah so that's why i mean birds of prey
was just
they were breaking the fourth wall type
of [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah i was
saying like it's like a guy richie
women's
empowerment dc film not nothing wrong
with women's empowerment or guy richard
it wasn't executed well though yeah it's
just the execution wasn't totally there
like yeah and i just and if you have a
fight film and the fighting choreography
is trash what the [ __ ] then what are we
sitting there waiting for exactly like
we're just waiting for it to be over the
best part of the film was just the
beginning where she snapped that dude's
kneecaps when she jumped out
like oh that's the best part of this
film yeah for me it was when she sniffed
the cocaine but then that's my own
problem too
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast what
other movies would you like us to review
i hope you enjoyed everything everywhere
all at once i have to watch it again
cause it's a really trippy ass [ __ ]
film it's wild it's off the walls
audacious
just one of the most
craziest films you'll see in this decade
and i'm glad it's doing well too because
it had a relatively slow start yeah and
i think people just didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was it's it's wild how they're
extending the theatrical release yeah it
was almost done because people keep
going back
so when i first tried to watch it there
was nobody in the theater and literally
the next week couldn't get a ticket
right because one week because
everyone's like you got to [ __ ] watch
this yep you have to watch this we the
first time we went in there was only
four people
and three of them were me ray and cliff
and somebody else yeah and then that was
it but then the next week try to get a
ticket all sold out
insane and that's and that's probably
how many weeks has it been in theaters a
long time now yeah yeah it's like a hot
spot that's [ __ ] and that's what's so
[ __ ] awesome about this film if it's
like
a lot of the people are just going back
to watch it again because they know they
missed something that's a great way to
make a film yeah
well guys you could catch ed at ed
parkvp and you could catch genius brains
um genius brains genius brain at 12 pm
on sundays and we'll see you all next
time peace